Residenz Leaper, Leute. Danke für den Sub, Michael. 50 Billiarden, 14 Monate. Huge Hyper Subscription hier.
Residenz Leaper, ich sag's euch. Hyper Residenz Leaper. Und auch nicht.
Alter, am Start hier mit der... Richard 50 Billiarden ist da, der Phipps ist da.
Days Code, Laupetin. Das hört sich an, wegen dem Medikament. Vielleicht ist es ja auch, keine Ahnung.
The Death Operator, FakeNet, Renex, Dennis K.E., Dom Leubel, Mario XCB, Synaptics, DeadPie, Chorius, Maxi, Mizarre, der Kalf ist auch am Start.
Jawoll, jetzt sind sie alle am Start. Bam. Leute, ich muss euch sagen, der YouTube Algorithmus versagt heute komplett bei mir.
Es wird nur Mist angezeigt. Also wirklich, YouTube Algorithmus ist heute eher so.
Ist wirklich nur Mist drin. Das heißt, wenn ihr irgendwelche guten Videos habt, die ihr gucken könnt, dann sagt Bescheid.
Ich hab ne neue Job. Nice. Pog. Was denn? Freedom Phone ist kein... Was ist denn das Freedom Phone jetzt schon wieder?
Okay, Freedom Phone. Das klingt nach Kokona-Style. Freedom Phone.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die jetzt ein Telefon brauchen für Freedom. Freedom bei denen ist doch, dass ich Maschinengewehr mitnehmen kann.
Reicht doch. Das Bauernvideo über Intel, das hab ich offen schon.
Stimmt, Level Cap, G-Baden. Was gibt's denn, was G-Baded uns Level Cap denn wieder?
Devs Talk, Battlefield 2042. Aha, aha. Was Devs Talken sie denn? Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich wette mir, das ist der gleiche Krempel, den sie uns auch schon erzählt haben, bloß nochmal etwas weiter ausgebreitet alles.
Wahrscheinlich ist da überhaupt nichts neu. Das BDO. Nee.
Als Software-Engineer-Solution-Architekt bei einem Consultant-Unternehmen. Big Brain Time.
Du kannst da Zertifikate machen, Pock. Welche Zertifikate? Ach so, ich hab jetzt an Let's Encrypt oder so gedacht. Hä? Warum geht das bloß Freitags? Ach, jetzt versteh ich's.
Wie findest du das? Was für ein Ding? Was ist das? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung. Ah, das Elektro-Fahrrad. Okay, kann ich nichts zu sagen. Keine Ahnung.
Der Cute-Bot ist eh ein bisschen broken in letzter Zeit. Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich am Cute-Bot selber, da kann man denke ich mal nicht viel machen.
Die hat ja auch in den letzten Tagen die Video, sag ich schon die, nur weil der Cute-Bot einen weiblichen Bot-Avatar hat. Die hat es in den letzten Tagen ein bisschen verkackt.
Auch Video-Ankündigungen kamen nicht, Stream-Ankündigungen kamen teilweise zu spät.
Aber Video hat auch nicht funktioniert gestern.
Ja, also ich kanns noch mal sagen, wenn ihr irgendwelche interessanten Videos habt, die wir heute gucken sollen, dann schickt mal her. Ich zeig euch das mal.
Der YouTube-Algorithmus versagt komplett heute bei mir.
Was ist das? So, ich refresh jetzt mal.
Was ist das? Peter Altmaier lässt sich nicht den Kuchen verboten. Warum krieg ich das empfohlen?
Gut, klar, das ist irgendeine Meme-Verarschung, sonst was, Video. She's a truck, who cares? Alter, was sind das für Video-Empfehlungen?
Was sind das für Video-Empfehlungen? Davon interessiert mich überhaupt nichts.
Was ist das hier? Das ist so fail. Was macht der Algorithmus? Guckt euch das mal an, da ist nur Crap dabei.
Das ist ja ich sag doch komplett. Bist du schon geimpft? Ja, einmal, einmal bin ich geimpft.
Das ist komplett, komplett.
Warum heißt es eigentlich Kaufmann-WMX? Warum heißt es nicht Kaufwinnen oder so?
Oder Kauffrauen und Kaufmänner und KaufXe oder irgendwie sowas? KaufX zum Beispiel, ja.
Es hat überhaupt keine Logik zu schreiben Kaufmann mit NN und dann WMX. Wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Man könnte es vielleicht Kaufmann nennen, so mit einem N. Ergibt alles wenig Sinn, gebe ich zu.
Gehaltsgespräch, kompletter Beispiele, das gucken wir uns nicht an. Das ist bestimmt total cringy, so schön gestellt.
Der Kaufmann, genau. Kaufmensch, Kaufperson.
Guck mal, ich kriege Videos von mir empfohlen. Muss man immer aufmachen. Immer wenn Videos von mir empfohlen werden, muss man die aufmachen.
Das gibt Algorithmusboost. Dann erstmal laufen lassen, easy.
Ich darf, auch wenn ich mir dieses Video jetzt tatsächlich angucken würde, ich darf diese Videos nicht angucken, weil der Algorithmus dann auch noch denkt, ich will das gucken.
Ich will diesen ganzen Kram nicht empfohlen bekommen. Präsentation, Fachinformatiker, Systemiergerda. Ich habe schon zwei Videoempfehlungen dazu bekommen, das reicht.
Wie ist denn jetzt eigentlich die korrekte Art und Weise, sowas zu schreiben?
Ich lese ja relativ viel im IT News Seiten und da setzt sich das auch immer mehr durch, dass man nicht schreibt Kaufmänner und Kauffrauen, sondern dass man irgendwie so diese neu erdachte allgemeingültige Schreibweise macht, so nach dem Motto InformatikerInnen.
Aber was ich nicht verstehe ist, wie schreibt man das jetzt eigentlich? Mit einem Sternchen, mit einem Unterstrich, mit einem Doppelpunkt, mit einem großen I oder mit einem kleinen I. Ich habe sogar schon mit Lehrzeichen gesehen. Wie ist jetzt da eigentlich richtig?
Also wie würde man Informatiker, außerdem ist das in der Aussprache auch übelst schwierig. Du musst anhand der Pause erkennen, ob du jetzt nur Frauen meinst oder beide. Ich finde das äußerst hakelig.
Ja, in C++ wäre das tatsächlich so. Also ich komme da nicht so ganz klar drauf, was denn da jetzt und was denn da jetzt nicht.
Wichtig ist doch, dass man weiß, wer gemeint ist. Was beneiden Japaner an Deutsch? Das juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Was ich an Japanern beneide, das kann ich euch sagen, dass da alles, zumindest so wie das immer in Videos aus, alles ultra sauber ist. Ich glaube sowas wie Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof gibt es in Japan nicht. Oder Berlin Hauptbahnhof. Sowas gibt es in Japan glaube ich nicht.
Wir überraschen ihn mit krassem Gaming Setup. Was ist mit dem Algorithmus los heute? Da ist ja nichts dabei. Wenn ich schon hauptsächlich meine eigenen Videos empfohlen kriege, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Okay, Gehalt eines Informatikers. Wollen wir wetten, Leute? Wollen wir wetten, wenn ich das Video aufmache, sitzt da nicht die rothaarige da aus dem Thumbnail vom Rechner? Wollen wir wetten? Bam. Ich wusste es.
Das war so klar. Aber ich würde auch so ein Thumbnail machen, da klickt man einfach drauf. She made it. Naja logisch. Es gibt nichts, der Algorithmus ist einfach unfähig heute.
Schnelltests, Trefferquote unter 50%. Wisst ihr was auch unter 50% ist? Die Likes bei den Videos, garantiert. Okay, ich hab mich vertan. Ich hab mich vertan, fast. Was das Video von der IHK?
Das haben wir schonmal geguckt. Das war glaube ich gar nicht so schlecht das Video. Auch wenn es ein bisschen an der Realität vorbei war. Aber die möchten, dass ich das nochmal gucke. Wir haben das vor 2 Jahren schonmal geguckt.
Guck mal, jetzt krieg ich mein Klo-Video empfohlen und daneben ein Tag Fachinformatiker. Das will ich aber doch jetzt nicht gucken. Es gibt nichts, es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Hey ihr alten Zerstörer. Das haben wir schon geguckt letzte Woche. Jetzt kriegen wir ein Plants vs Zombies Tutorial in 2021 Leute. Der YouTube Algorithmus heute ist komplett lost.
Wir machen jetzt mal was. Wir gucken mal, wieso der 0815 Besucher in Deutschland YouTube sieht. Ach du Scheiße. Das ist ja noch schlimmer. Ich hab gedacht das hier wäre noch schlimmer. Ach du Scheiße.
Der 0815 Noob hat doch kein Dark Mode an. Ach du Scheiße, was krieg ich denn hier für einen Müll? Das hab ich geguckt vor einer Woche oder so.
Zerstörte Dörfer an der A. Was haben sie denn jetzt? Das ist scheiße, aber das muss ich mir jetzt nicht nochmal angucken. Es wird davon nicht besser.
Dieses Video hat hauptsächlich so viele Klicks, weil dort auf dem Thumbnail eine steht, die so gut wie nichts anhat. Die Leute denken sich so nach dem Motto, dieses Bild muss ich mir mal in groß angucken und machen dann das Video auf.
Und dann kommt das noch nicht mal in den Video, dann fährt er so ein komisches Schiff. Also immer ganz im Ernst, YouTube hier Startseite, das ist ja noch schlimmer als das was ich empfohlen krieg.
Das ist nichts für mich, Alter. Wahnsinn.
Es ist heute, also der Algorithmus ist procken, das Wochenende.
Lasst Dokus von der Flut schauen, nee, das ist ein äußerst deprimierendes Thema, das muss ich mir nicht angucken. Außerdem wird es davon nicht besser, wenn wir uns das angucken. Also ihr seht, es gibt nur Müll auf YouTube gerade, außer natürlich das da, das ist gut, das sollt ihr euch alle angucken.
Ihr wisst ja, eigene Videos immer öffnen, das ist gut für den Algorithmus.
Perfekt.
Impfpflicht ohne Impfung keine Freiheit.
Also, dazu kann ich nur sagen, ich lasse mich impfen in zwei Wochen, aber sollte wirklich jemand auf die Idee kommen und zu sagen, ich muss mich impfen lassen, sonst gibt es Strafe, dann bin ich der Erste der das absagt.
Ich mache das freiwillig, weil ich es für den Sinn behalte, aber ich hasse es, bevormundet zu werden. Es gibt kaum etwas, was ich mehr hasse, als wenn mir irgendjemand sagen soll, was ich machen soll, selbst wenn ich der gleichen Ansicht bin.
Also wenn irgendjemand sagt, du musst was machen, sonst musst du Strafe bezahlen, dann sag ich, leck mich, mach ich nicht.
Aber so wird es wahrscheinlich, soweit wird es wahrscheinlich nicht kommen.
So schlimm war die Gaming Night der Jungen Union. Oh, das ist Pains Champ. Das ist richtig.
Da kann dann Philipp Amthor wieder sagen, hallo ihr alten Zerstörer. So was hier, genau, ihr alten Zerstörer.
Stimmt es, dass man mit der Impfung nur sich selbst schützt? Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Aber kann ja an sich nicht stimmen. Selbst wenn du es bekommst, selbst wenn du noch ansteckend wärst, bist du es wahrscheinlich nicht so lang und nicht so sehr.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber es reicht schon, wenn ich mich selbst schütze. Das reicht mir ehrlich gesagt schon.
Das ist schon genug für mich. Das ist okay.
So, es ist, was Pegasus spielen wird und wie wir uns schützen. Auf dem neuen iPhone geht das Kram gar nicht mehr.
Oder? Vor allem Apple untersucht. Aha.
Okay, praktisches Beispiel für Gutrechte. Oh, das ist Big Brain Time. Das ist Big Brain Time.
Ist schon. Ach, guck mal. Ach, guck mal, wenn man die Videos anklickt, dann gehen sie aus der Empfehlung raus.
Das heißt, ich muss den Mist, den ich nicht gucken will, erst anklicken, dass ich ihn nicht mehr empfohlen bekomme oder was?
Okay, das ist ja Feifett. Aber wenn ich den Mist anklicke, damit ich ihn nicht mehr empfohlen bekomme, denkt YouTube, ich gucke ihn gerne und empfiehlt mir noch mehr davon.
Das ist eigentlich die painst-champigste-Variante rauszuholen. Nee, ich kann nicht anklicken, dass ich kein Interesse habe, weil ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Into users. Nein, ich will wirklich ein gescheites Video gucken, nicht irgendwelche Meme-Videos.
Das geht nur, wenn man eingeloggt ist. Was ich übrigens total hängen geblieben finde, das würde auch genauso gut funktionieren, wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Die machen ja eh ein Profil von meinem User, auch wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Macht doch einen Stream-Account.
Ja, kann ich machen, aber warum? Normalerweise klappt es ja auch so.
So, dann, dann. Da müssen wir jetzt erstmal zum Entspannen eine Runde.
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal Chibane von Levelcap. Wo ist das hier?
Okay, meine Videos mache ich mal dicht.
Wo ist der Levelcap, Chibane? Anderes Fenster.
Du musst anklicken, 5 Sekunden gucken, dann zumachen. Aha.
Das ist aber normal, dass innerhalb der ersten 5 Sekunden, keine Ahnung, 30%, 40% der Leute abschalten.
Okay, sag mal, ich glaube bei mir schalten innerhalb der ersten, also bei mir sind nach den ersten irgendwie 30 Sekunden im Durchschnitt glaube ich noch irgendwie 75% der Zuschauer dabei.
Also es ist normal, dass 25-30% erstmal instant quitten.
Freedom Phone.
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt von Levelcap Chibane. Da ist bestimmt nichts interessantes dabei.
Aber da Chibatet uns immer der Kerl. Also Chibane.
Jawoll.
Ich mag die Aussprache von Amis von Multiplayer. Die sagen Multiplayer.
Overwatch 2, Alter.
Kennst du schon die neue Avira Werbung? Angeblich schützt Avira.
Nee, kenne ich nicht. Haben die den Video? Schick mal, das gucken wir uns her und ketten eine Runde.
Kennen wir noch alles.
Ich dachte Hazard Zone sollte genauso was werden. Mal gucken.
Gut, Incursion. Incursion erinnert sich noch an Incursion, Alter.
Incursion war ja komplett, komplett dead. Das ist ja noch nicht mal released worden.
Incursions wurde angekündigt und dann kam eine Beta raus, es hat keine Sau interessiert und dann wurde es nie fertig gemacht.
Die hatten ja damals noch so ein Reveal Video, wo die ganzen, wo irgendwelche angeblichen E-Sport Pros gesessen haben und haben das gespielt.
Keiner davon war ein E-Sport Pro. Ich glaube, der, der, der, den einzigen, den ich davon gekannt habe, das war aber auch kein E-Sport Pro.
Es war, kennt noch einer, Whiteboy7street, der hat früher Call of Duty Videos gemacht.
Der war in diesem Video noch dabei, wo ich mir gedacht habe, was zum Geier macht der Typ da?
Und es hat keinen interessiert.
Incursion ist Passive Exile League, ja, stimmt.
Dabei könnte man das, dabei könnte man das machen.
Ich habe das schon oft gesagt, ich bin der Ansicht, Squad Rush, vielleicht nicht unbedingt zu viert.
Vielleicht könnte man das irgendwie zu einem 6 versus 6 erweitern oder sowas.
Vier ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig, 5 versus 5, 6 versus 6.
Squad Rush auf gescheiten Maps, finde ich, ist der battlefieldigste E-Sport Modus, den man machen könnte.
Hier die Werbung.
Oh nee, das ist bestimmt Cringe Werbung.
So, gleich gucken.
Ach, das geht ja nur 17 Sekunden, das ist ja nichts. Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwas Paintschampiges.
Aha.
Okay, man nimmt also ein Bild, was zwar von dem Wort her was mit dem Thema zu tun hat,
aber von dem Ereignis her nichts mit dem Thema zu tun hat.
Nee, Publish ich nicht auf GitHub.
Außerdem, die Katz will den Fischgard fangen, wenn die den Fisch hätte fangen wollen, das würde anders aussehen.
Okay, das ist ja kaum was zu sagen zu der Werbung.
Awesome, ja, alles klar, huge.
Ja, kann man nichts zu sagen, aber warum Protected Avira vor Fishing-Angriffen?
Guck das beispielsweise, wenn du persönliche Informationen überträgst, in irgendein Feld eintippst oder sowas.
Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass eine, nennen wir es mal irgendwie Antivirus,
das ist ja nicht wirklich reine Antivirus-Software, sowas wie Avira, dass das potentiell schon was dagegen machen kann.
Das habe ich vergessen rein zu machen, Wubbetke.
Wubbetke, das habe ich hier nur gesprochen, stimmt, muss ich noch rein machen.
Immer dieses gleiche Gelaber.
Also ich dachte eigentlich Hazard Zone wird so eine Art Competitive-Modus.
Die sagen ja Squad-Play, High-Stakes, bla, bla, bla.
Und wenn Hazard Zone halt standardmäßig nicht drin ist, okay, dann kommt es später.
Aber ich würde es sehr wundern, wenn die das nicht machen.
Ich meine, die hätten, die würden, guck mal, die würden doch ganz schön viel Potenzial,
vor allem für ein Spiel, das sie über Jahre supporten wollen.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, mal gucken und nicht, dass sie es wieder in Battlefield 5 machen.
Für ein Spiel, das sie Jahre supporten wollen, wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube, es wäre sehr teuer, wenn sie jetzt schon Battle Royale Links liegen lassen
und wenigstens nicht mal den Versuch unternehmen würden, das ein bisschen Competitive spielbar zu machen.
Dann würden sie auch viel Links liegen lassen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Und ich glaube ja übrigens immer noch nicht dran,
dass sie nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise auf Battlefield Battle Royale noch schielen.
Ja gut, das ist ja beknackt. Das ist ja beknackt.
Das ist das Problem, wenn du keine Plugins mehr bei Servern installieren kannst.
Bei Battlefield 4, da konntest du, bei Battlefield 1 Servern weiß ich es nicht,
aber bei Battlefield 4 Servern, da konntest du beispielsweise noch Server Plugins installieren.
Da hattest du ja auch noch eine richtige Server-Konsole und alles.
Und da konntest du auch übergreifende Buns implementieren.
Das ist halt das Problem, wenn man das alles so restriktiv macht.
Das ist halt für'n Arsch.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, viele Leute wurden ja auch gerade, also richtig gute Leute,
wurden ja auch in Battlefield 4 gebannt.
Die haben dann 5 Accounts gebraucht, weil die einfach gut gespielt haben.
Und irgendein Server-Typ sich gedacht hat, ne ne ne, das kann nicht sein.
Also, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ob die jetzt Frostbite-Code geklaut haben oder nicht, ist doch vollkommen unerheblich.
Es gibt jetzt schon massig Hex für alle Battlefield, also Hex ist vielleicht das Fall,
Cheats. Was ist Cheats für alle Battlefields?
Und es ist doch, warum sollte es einen Frostbite-Code-Leak, wie auch immer, brauchen,
dass jemand für Battlefield 2042 Cheats entwickelt?
Das kannste doch vergessen.
Das wird auch so passieren.
Gut, vielleicht macht es das jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise einfacher,
aber das bezweifle ich sogar.
Dass es einen endeswerten Unterschied macht.
Ach, es wird, es wird, also ich sag euch jetzt wie es ist.
Die Beta von diesem Game ist spielbar.
Und es gibt, wenn nicht ab dem ersten Tag, dann gibt es ab dem zweiten Tag Cheats,
die funktionieren.
Die Frage ist nicht, ob es Cheats geben wird.
Die Frage ist, wie geht EA gegen Cheats vor?
Cheats wirst du nicht verhindern können.
Oder auf dem PC besonders schwer.
Wie geht EA dagegen vor?
Was hat EA für Möglichkeiten, da was zu erkennen?
Und was hat EA auch für Möglichkeiten, quasi automatisiert,
also über irgendwelche statistischen Auswertungen.
Meinetwegen, wenn wir 2021 sind, dass man dann auch sagt,
ey Bäm, per Machine Learning, was auch immer, da Statistiken zu untersuchen,
ob das Cheating-Potenzial hat.
Das ist die Frage, was sie dagegen machen.
Das kostet richtig Geld.
Wenn die Machine Learning AI-Cheats kommen, dann ist eh vorbei.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das gibt ein neues Wettrennen zwischen Cheat Detection und Cheats.
Also es gibt ja jetzt schon genug Cheats, die nicht wirklich erkennbar sind.
Da hatten wir, da hatten wir es ja vor.
Da wollte ich übrigens auch mal ein Video zu machen.
Muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Also da hatten wir ja vor einer Weile, da habe ich mich auch mal dazu geäußert.
Also es gibt ja jetzt schon einen Haufen Cheats, die praktisch nicht erkennbar sind.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so verbreitet.
Da gibt es mehrere Varianten.
Es gibt die komplett unabhängige Variante.
Also du hast ein Capture Device dran und du hast ein Input Device dran.
Also es wird nicht direkt auf den Arbeitsspeicher zugegriffen vom Spiel.
Also du merkst das nicht.
Das Einzige, was die Cheats machen, ist Output abgreifen und Input liefern.
Gibt es vor Valorant beispielsweise schon was.
Da kannst du in Valorant, da schleifst du das durch eine Capture Karte durch,
analysierst die Bilder und dann hast du quasi Input an der Maus, der für dich triggert und sowas.
Es ist eigentlich auf dem Rechner selbst und undetectable, weil du nichts auf dem Rechner drauf hast.
So, dann hast du die nächste Variante, die eigentlich auch nicht wirklich zu detekten ist, die aber sogar noch besser funktioniert,
weil du keine AI trainieren musst.
Es gibt die Variante, dass du Hardware einbaust in den Rechner, die sich tarnt als, sagen wir mal, Netzwerkkarte oder irgendwas.
Also irgendwas, was die unmöglich bannen können, weil jeder eine Netzwerkkarte hat.
Und diese Hardware greift über einen Windows-Treiber auf den Arbeitsspeicher zu.
Also als PCI-Express-Gerät auf den Arbeitsspeicher vom Spiel.
Das ist auch nicht wirklich detektbar.
Und dann macht es Dinge damit auf einem externen Microcontroller und schickt beispielsweise auch Inputs an die Maus und die Tastatur.
Also das sind beide Sachen, die sind so gut wie nicht detektbar.
Aber, und selbst wenn wir mal beide Sachen nehmen, aber natürlich ist es in gewisser Weise schon zu erkennen.
Allerdings nicht kleinzeitig, sondern da muss man sich halt überlegen,
okay, wie erkenne ich bestimmte Muster in den Statistiken, die man aufteilt.
Die Games müssen sau viele Statistiken sammeln, ja.
Da reicht es nicht nur so nach dem Motto, wie viel Damage pro Sekunde mache ich.
Die müssen sammeln Damage pro Sekunde, wie genau ist quasi mein Aiming, wie oft überame ich, wie schnell erkenne ich.
Zum Beispiel, das ist auch so eine Sache, wie schnell erkenne ich von, da ist ein Gegner zu der ersten Reaktion.
Das ist ja auch so was, das ist AI-technisch instant, je nachdem, wenn du keine Delays einbaust, und das werden sie dann auch machen.
So nach dem Motto, ich erkenne Gegner, reagiere instant, aber versuche dann mein Aim ein bisschen zu verschleiern.
Also, was ich damit sagen will ist, ich glaube, das wird einfach ein komplett neues Wettrüsten auslösen zwischen AI-Cheats und AI-Anti-Cheat.
Und es ist nicht abzusehen, wer das Ganze gewinnt.
Wahrscheinlich wird das gar keiner gewinnen, und es wird einfach so weitergehen wie die letzten Jahre, dass es, je nachdem, was für einen Hersteller man erwischt, mal mehr, mal weniger gut funktioniert.
Naja, gut, das kannst du machen, aber du kannst es ja einfach ändern.
Also, wenn du eine Hardware hast, wo du dann auch noch flashen kannst, als welche Sache, die sich wählt, und du wirst im Leben nicht eine Hardware sperren können, die eine 0815-Netzwerkkarte ist.
Wie willst du das machen?
Zumal, die immer eine andere Mac hat, die immer eine leicht andere ID hat, da wirst du nichts dagegen machen, das sage ich ja.
Die Sachen sind theoretisch zwar feststellbar, aber sau schwer. Cheats, die nur Output ausgreifen und Input liefern, sind überhaupt nicht feststellbar.
Also es ist echt schwierig mittlerweile, deswegen müssen die auch Anti-Cheat technisch aufrüsten.
So, machen wir mal weiter.
Wir haben es jetzt geschafft, 20 Minuten über 1,55 Video zu reden, exellent.
Technical Preview würde ich jetzt auch nicht erwarten, dass das richtig gut läuft.
Das ist doch gut. Das ist doch gut. Es wird mal wieder Zeit für einen ordentlichen Halo Multiplayer, den die Leute auch länger als zwei Monate spielen. Das letzte Mal Halo 3.
Halo 3 MLG Playlist.
Chat, chat, klärt mich auf, welche, welche Space Frogs Sache, äh, hä? Chat, ihr müsst mir das erklären. Five Hat Time.
Bungie soll mal wieder Halo machen, das wirst du nicht mehr erleben.
Ja, das kennen wir ja schon.
Die junge Union hat ein Gaming Stream gemacht mit Ampton und irgendwie hat da mitgelongt, was im Chat alles gelöscht wurde.
Das heißt, irgendwer hast du das mitgeloggt? Ich meine, irgendwie muss ja jetzt der Chat auf dich kommen, so nach dem Motto, irgendwas musst du ja damit zu tun haben.
Hacker-Mans im Chat wieder hier.
Vielleicht war ich da involviert, ja.
Ja, das kennen wir schon. Das kennen wir schon und die Antworten von den Activision Blizzard Management Leuten war halt überall komplett lächerlich, durch die Bank weg.
Am besten fand ich die Antwort von der, war das die Inklusions-Antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte oder so? Ich weiß nicht, welche Position das ist.
Die die geschrieben hat, dass es bei Activision Blizzard jetzt Anti-Sexismus, Anti-Rassismus, Anti-Diskriminierungs-, Anti-Mobbing-Kurse gibt und jetzt ist alles gut.
Weil, ich stell mir das so vor, du hast irgendjemand, der sich wahnsinnig darüber freut, andere Leute abzufacken.
Der macht das richtig Spaß, der wird dann in so einen Anti-Mobbing-Kurs geschickt und die sagen ihm dann, das ist aber nicht okay und dann sagt er, ach, da bin ich nie drauf gekommen.
Jetzt gut, dass sie mir das mal sagen, ich hätte nie damit gerechnet, dass das andere Leute abfackt.
Das heißt, ich werde es jetzt weiterhin machen, aber nicht mehr so offensichtlich.
Das ist dann die Reaktion der Leute drauf, die machen es dann einfach weniger offensichtlich, ja.
Genau, für den ist es eine Schulung, wie er noch mehr Leute abfacken kann oder geheime abfacken kann.
Wisst ihr, mir ist es lieber, es macht einer öffentlich, so nach dem Motto, keine Ahnung, man sitzt in einem Meeting und sagt einer, Max, dein Vorschlag ist scheiße wie immer.
So, das ist mir lieber, als wenn irgendwie einer so ultra passiv-aggressiv ist. Keine Ahnung, da fällt mir jetzt kein gutes Beispiel dazu ein.
Aber wisst ihr, wenn man das dann versteckter macht, so nach dem Motto, ihr werdet mir doch sicher Recht geben, niemand würde solch einen Vorschlag ernst...
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine, dass man das dann nicht so offensichtlich macht, also mir ist es wirklich lieber, jemand macht das direkt, weil dann kannst du auch dementsprechend darauf antworten.
Da kannst du sagen, ja, alter, fick dich, so übertrieben gesagt, ja, anstatt immer so durch die Blume, so um die Ecke.
Weil dann, wenn du jemand anscheißt dafür und es bekommen Leute mit, die das andere nicht konstant mitbekommen, dann denken die, du bist der Böse, weil du den jetzt angeschissen hast.
Versteht man, was ich meine? Also das heißt, mit solchen Anti-Mobbing-Kursen bringst du den Leuten dann wahrscheinlich nur auf den Trichter, dass die jetzt das Ganze ein bisschen hinterhältiger machen müssen.
So, weiter. Ja, macht's auch, macht's auch.
Ja, also mir fällt übrigens ein gutes Beispiel, mir ist jetzt ein gutes Beispiel eingefallen, was so passiv-aggressiv wäre, zum Beispiel.
Also direkt in your face wäre so noch der Motto, Max, dein Vorschlag ist scheiße wie immer.
So, wenn das jemand auf dem Meeting sagt, kannst du wenigstens dementsprechend darauf reagieren.
Aber wenn zum Beispiel jemand sagt, wir sollten ein öffentliches, also du machst einen Vorschlag, ja, und irgendjemand sagt dann, wir sollten ein öffentliches Board für schlechte Ideen einrichten.
So was in der Richtung, ja. Das ist nicht so direkt, Max, du bist scheiße, das ist so, hat eigentlich gar nichts so direkt damit zu tun, aber es ist klar, auf was es sich bezieht, ja.
So was. Und die Leute lernen es dann eher mit der Zeit, dass sie das noch hinterhältiger machen müssen, was auch nicht gut ist. Also wenn schon, sollen sie es eher direkt machen.
Dann kannst du dementsprechend darauf reagieren.
Ja, nee, nee, nee, deine Ideen sind immer ResidentSleeper, ist ja auch direkt, das bezieht sich ja direkt auf mich. Es gibt aber Leute, die haben das perfektioniert, die sagen dann nicht mehr so noch dem Motto, deine Idee ist scheiße, die drücken das so um die Ecke aus.
So nach dem Motto, wir sollten auch mal einen Review Prozess etablieren, der Ideen von solchen Meetings unter die Lupe nimmt, so nach dem Motto. Wisst ihr, wo du eigentlich genau weißt, was Sache ist, aber er meint im Prinzip, deine Idee ist scheiße und möchte das auch so verpacken, aber es nicht direkt sagen.
Genau, genau, das ist auch so nach dem Motto, gibt es hier auch noch gute Ideen oder sowas.
Aber es gibt Leute, die haben das drauf, die können quasi schon nicht mehr anders reden als so. Die müssen jedes Kommentar irgendwie so spicken, als sind sie die Schlausten und alles andere ist doof.
Das ist wirklich ätzend.
Hat es überhaupt irgendjemand gekauft, die neue Xbox?
Ja, genau sowas wäre auch mal. Okay, ich habe mir jetzt den Vorschlag notiert und dann irgendwie noch sowas dabei zu sagen, das müssen wir aber dann noch mal im Detail genau erklären, ich sehe da noch einige Probleme oder irgendwie sowas.
Man kann es ganz schwer sagen, es kommt von Situation zu Situation zu Person zu Person an. Wisst ihr, so zu allen anderen Vorschlägen sagen, das ist cool, super guter Vorschlag und bei deinem, wenn ihr euch nicht abkönnt, dann immer sowas einbauen.
Wie heißen die jetzt eigentlich richtig? Xbox Series X und Xbox Series S.
Wo?
Sieht ja auch Resident Sleeper aus.
Ach, das ist das, wo die dann in so einem Raumanzug landen und survive müssen, haben wir irgendwo mal einen Trailer gesehen. Hat mich jetzt auch nicht persönlich, sondern nicht gejuckt.
Ja, genau das Ding, das da meine ich ja.
Wisst ihr, als hätten wir jetzt ein neues, weiteres Survival Crafting Game gebraucht. Das ist wie vor ein paar Jahren, wo alle paar Wochen ein neues Zombie Game rausgekommen ist. Gibt es wirklich noch Leute, die sagen, oh ja, unbedingt Survival Game mit Crafting Elementen, das ist es jetzt, da brauchen wir noch mehr von. Am besten noch mit Battle Royale.
Ist eigentlich Warts irgendwann mal fertig geworden? Was ja nicht mal Warts heißt, was ja jetzt Infestation, Survivor Stories oder so heißt.
Ist das jemals fertig geworden?
Oder was ist mit dem Klassiker Dates? Ist Dates irgendwann mal fertig geworden?
Das hat eh jeder vergessen.
Würdest du das Riot Games MMO mal testen? Auf jeden Fall. Würde ich auf jeden Fall ausprobieren, was es gibt. Ich habe zwar mit LOL nichts am Hut, aber ich traue Riot Games auf jeden Fall zu, ein ordentliches MMO zu machen. Mehr als Amazon.
Die haben aber auch den riesen Vorteil. Wisst ihr was? Also meine persönliche Meinung, ich denke, dass League of Legends, wenn man so weit geht und sagt, dass irgendjemand mal wieder was in Größe wie WoW produzieren könnte, ich denke, dass die einzige Firma, die das machen könnte aktuell tatsächlich Riot ist, weil der Hype in World of Warcraft damals war ja durch mehrere Sachen ausgelöst.
Erstens, es war eines der ersten so richtigen Mainstream tauglichen MMOs. Auch ein richtig gutes MMO. Und die Leute waren halt riesige Warcraft Fanboys vorher schon.
Und so ist es bei LOL auch. LOL hat eine riesen Fanbase. LOL hat bis jetzt nie so wirklich großartig was mit Story gemacht. Die haben natürlich, es gibt ja diese, es ist ja, die LOL Story ist ja irgendwie so, du bist ein Summoner, also du bist quasi irgendwie so ein Gedankensteuer Dude und dann hast du da deine Matches, wo du irgendwelche Champions Gedankensteuerst oder was auch immer.
So, also großartige Stories haben die ja noch nie in LOL eingebaut. Aber die haben jetzt da seit einem Jahr oder wann das war, die LOL ist überarbeitet. Ja, das meine ich ja. Seit einem Jahr oder seit zwei Jahren haben die das voll ausgebaut.
Die wollen jetzt ja auch eine Serie machen. Und die haben jetzt ja auch, wie gesagt, ich bin nicht so wahnsinnig drin, was League of Legends angeht. Aber die haben jetzt ja auch eine Worldmap und Erklärungen zu verschiedenen Orten und sonst was.
Also die haben da richtig, was die Summoner sind, gestrichen. Okay, kein Outside, keine Ahnung. Zumindest die sind da richtig gut dabei. Und die haben einen Vorteil, den Wo damals auch hatte, das ist, die haben schon eine riesen Fanbase, bevor das Game rauskommt.
Und ich könnte mir echt vorstellen, dass das, wenn das ein gutes Game wird, dass das richtig, dass das richtig reinhaut. Ich meine, die haben es mit Valorant ja auch geschafft, ein Game rauszuhauen, was komplett anders ist als LOL.
Aber sich doch ganz gut spielt. Wobei ich sagen muss, Valorant, also ich habe es, ich gucke ab und zu mal ein bisschen Valorant. Ich habe das nie selbst gespielt. Ich finde aber die Streams teilweise ganz, ganz unterhaltsam. Was mir persönlich rein als Zuschauer in Valorant so ein bisschen negativ auffällt, sind die Maps.
Die Maps sehen etwas, wie soll ich sagen, also mir geht es jetzt nicht um die Spielbarkeit oder so, da kann ich nichts dazu sagen. Die Maps sehen ein bisschen aus, als wären die, sagen wir mal, als wären die Level Designer jetzt nicht die allergrößten Rose.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von der Spielbarkeit, sondern wie die Maps gemacht sind. Die wirken auf mich vom Anschauen teilweise eben ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen amateurhaft, das ist falsch. Ich könnte es garantiert nicht besser.
Genau, man fragt sich, was die Level Designer beruflich machen, aber gar nicht so sehr von der Spielbarkeit, da kann ich nichts dazu sagen. Die Maps sehen an sich einfach nicht gut durchdacht aus. Wenn ich dann zum Beispiel sehe, wie da manche Maps zusammenhängen, das mag ja vom Layout okay sein für die Spielbarkeit, aber es ergibt einfach in sich geschlossen von so einer, so eine Map erzählt ja auch immer eine gewisse Story, ja.
Die eine Map, nennen wir jetzt mal eine Overwatch Map, nennen wir jetzt mal King's Row, das ist ein ganz klares Theme, so nach dem Motto, es ist ein futuristisches London. Also sprich, das sieht stimmig aus, wohingegen die meisten Valorant Maps eher so aussehen, als hat man Räume aneinander geordnet und zwischendrin mal Räume, wo man die Decke weggelassen hat.
So ungefähr sehen Valorant Maps aus. Die sehen nicht aus wie ein natürliches Gebiet, was zwar vielleicht der Spielbarkeit wegen nicht ganz realistisch ist, aber irgendwie ein sinnvolles Setting vermittelt.
Die Valorant Maps sehen halt wirklich so aus, als hat man sich erstmal ein halbwegs spielbares Layout überlegt und dann wusste man nicht, wie man das in eine sinnvolle Thematik einbinden kann.
Es ist schwierig, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht täuscht das auch als Zuschauer, aber Valorant Maps sehen halt für mich aus, Raum, Raum, Raum, Gang, Raum, wo man die Decke weggelassen hat, Raum, Raum, also das ist alles sehr rechteckig und unlogisch zusammen.
Also du läufst anerst durch einen Gang, wo irgendwie ein großes Tor ist, was aussieht wie von einer Industrieanlage und auf einmal stehst du, obwohl da nichtmal eine Eingangstür ist, sondern etwas in einem Wohnzimmer, was dann aber nicht weiter geht, was aber ein großes Fenster auf dem Bomben-Spot hat oder so.
Das ist zwar in CS auch so, aber in CS, die haben den Vorteil, die haben die meisten Maps wenigstens so ein bisschen, entweder sowas wie das, so ein bisschen in außen gelegenen Regionen oder industriemäßig sowas wie Cache gemacht, da ergibt es noch irgendwie Sinn, dass da Lagerhaus in Lagerhalle und Luftschacht und so geht, das passt schon.
Aber wenn ich mal beispielsweise Valorant, ich weiß nicht wie die Map heißt, die hat so eine Wüste-Textur, Boden und du läufst durch so eine Art Dusche oder Bad vom Spawn zum Bombenpunkt auf der rechten Seite.
Da pieken die Leute auch immer in dieses Bad rein oder Bad, Dusche, ich weiß nicht, was das ist, das ist irgendwie, es sieht aus als so ein gekachelter Raum und da denke ich mir immer so, das passt thematisch da null hin, das ist ein Gang, ein Gang, ein Ding und dann Bomben-Spot, wo man den Skybox oben draufgepappt, also es passt irgendwie nicht so richtig zusammen.
Das bind, Moment, Moment, ja genau die meine ich, ja genau, genau, ah Garden nennt sich das, Garden nennt sich das, Moment, das ist Defender, ich meine Attacker, das hier mein, Bad, das heißt tatsächlich Bad.
Ok, wenigstens, wenigstens man hat das als Bad erkannt, das bin ich ja schon mal froh, ich wusste nicht, dass das Bad heißt.
Genau und ich finde, das ist übrigens noch eine der, wie soll ich sagen, besser zusammen passenden Maps in Valorant, rein aus Zuschauersicht jetzt by the way, ich spiele das nicht.
Aber man sieht schon, das ist alles extrem, extrem rechteckig, so nach dem Motto Raum, Raum, Raum und hier hat man dann gesagt, ok hier ist eine Halle und hier ist ein Raum, warum ist denn hier eigentlich die Decke weg, warum, warum ist hier die Decke weg, so nach dem Motto, das ergibt irgendwie alles wenig zusammenhängenden Sinn in diesem Setting.
Aber das ist auch eines der besseren Maps, also ich finde, die Valorant Level Designer müssten sich mal ein bisschen Inspiration holen von anderen Games, dass man auch gute Maps bauen kann, die ein stimmiges Setting haben, was in irgendeiner Art und Weise plausibel erscheint, das ist das was ich meine, ja.
Die Overwatch Maps haben auch viele Gameplay technische Probleme, aber die sind wenigstens plausibel vom Aufbau her irgendwie.
Ich null.
Der Lead Designer hat Cache erstellt, ja ungefähr so sehen die Maps ja auch aus, nur dass es bei Cache passt, weil Cache Industriegebiet ist.
Cache ist auch so eine Map, wo man gesagt hat, Viereck an Viereck an Viereck an Viereck, Luftschacht dazwischen, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es bei Cache irgendwie dank Industriegebiet noch halbwegs passt.
Aber Bind ist ja so ein Zwischending aus, was soll Bind eigentlich darstellen als Valorant Map? Ist es, das ist ja auch das Ding, das ist so ein bisschen Vorstadt oder sowas, keine Ahnung, aber es ergibt keinen Sinn.
Was soll das eigentlich sein? Du hast Wohnhäuser, die keine Häuser sind, du hast irgendwelche komischen offenen Flächen, dann hast du einen Bad zwischendrin, keine Ahnung, es ergibt einfach keinen Sinn.
Sieht nach einem Industriepark aus, ja aber warum hast du dann auf einmal einen Bad zwischendrin?
Oder warum hast du auf einmal ein Wohnzimmer? Wie nennt sich das Wohnzimmer eigentlich in den Callouts? Sekunde. Wie nennt sich das Wohnzimmer? Window.
Okay, das ist ein Wohnzimmer, was auf einmal hier random drinne ist in der Map. Hier, das hier ist einfach ein Wohnzimmer random.
Das ist einfach ein Wohnzimmer zwischendrinne irgendwie.
Okay, ja das da meine ich ja. Spielbar ist die Map sicherlich nicht schlecht, ja.
Aber gesamtmäßig sieht es einfach nicht stimmig aus. Und das ist noch eines der besseren Maps.
Nein vom Zuschauen her.
Okay Chet, es muss anscheinend wirklich was dran sein, dass das in dem Space, dass J4Peak in den Spacebox Videos am Start ist. Der natürlich, er hat natürlich nichts damit zu tun logischerweise, ja.
Also es wäre möglich, dass er sich vielleicht für solche Themen mal auch interessiert.
Naja, also sowas sollte ja Standard sein, dass ich auswählen kann, wo ich den Download speichere, oder? Das ist jetzt kein super Feature Reveal, oder?
Was? Was? Was? Hab ich noch? Okay, ich bin outdated, was ist das?
Das heißt, es ist schon mal nicht in Java programmiert.
Okay, nice, schön. Schön Jibane lassen von Levelcap, alles klar. So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an? Das Freedom Phone.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, das hat jemand im Chat gepostet. Ich gucke ab und zu mal Videos von ihm, wobei ich sagen muss, manche Einstellungen sind mir zu, ich glaube nicht, dass man radikal sagen kann, aber irgendwie zu realitäts incompatibel.
So, gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, Freedom Phone. Was so geil ist das? Das muss ich jetzt mal angucken. Freedom Phone. Kekona Time. Freedom Phone. Oh, was? Ah, ich bin kein DDoS Angreifer, nein, nein, nein.
Schau es dir einfach an, meinst du, er zeigt dann genug? Ja, gucken wir uns an, gut ist.
Und Vacation. Natürlich. Ich muss sagen, dieses Emote passt da unglaublich gut hin, als würde es in der Seite schon startmäßig drin sein.
Okay, das ist just Kekona-Things.
Was? Von was spricht er überhaupt? Ich kann ihm nicht folgen.
Was? Hä? Ich komme nicht mal mit, das ist mir zu viel.
Bei der Way, wisst ihr was auch sinnvoll ist? Einfach verschlüsselten Messenger verwenden, da kann auch keiner so wirklich was censoren. Außer, außer, außer, der Hersteller liefert in seinem Betriebssystem irgendwelche Texterkennung aus oder so, was es anzeigt. Ja, vielleicht. Aber ich glaube, das ist erstmal nicht, wo man sich unmittelbar Gerneken darüber machen muss.
China-Chinesen-Phone, also ein China-Phone klingt ja schon mal extrem nach Freedom.
Freedom OS, also eine Sache kann man sich ja schon mal merken, wenn irgendwie was so
Branding-technisch komplett auf so eine Sache hinzieht, dann stimmt das meistens nicht.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn dir irgendeinen Coach erzählt werde, reich in einer Woche.
Das ist auch Schwachsinn. Also alles, was so komplett in eine Richtung zielt und alles
da drauf getrimmt ist, ist meistens nicht so. Die eine Temple OS nehmen können und portieren
auf armen. Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich so diese Haupt-Selling-
Point von dieser Geschichte? Dass er sagt, es ist unzensierbar. Das stimmt ja überhaupt
nicht. Spätestens von ihm ist es zensierbar, wenn es einen zentralen App-Store und zentrale
Update-Server gibt. Also unzensierbar ergibt ja in dem Fall schon mal gar keinen Sinn.
Ja, das weiß ich. Er ist ja da schon ziemlich hart drauf. Also ich würde mir im Leben kein
Gen2 holen, wo ich dann erst mal, wenn ich einen E-Mail-Anhang bekomme, den ich nicht
öffnen kann, zwei Stunden was kompilieren muss. Aber jeder wie er will, oder?
Da waren die Leute in meinem vorletzten Video total überrascht. Ich habe ja gesagt, dass
es unter iOS keinen anderen Browser als Safari gibt. Natürlich gab es wieder die üblichen
Diskussionen. Aber da hat jemand einen Kommentar geschrieben. Wie ist das? Nee, der hat geschrieben,
du hast den DuckDuckGo Browser vergessen. Das kann doch kein Safari sein. So in der
Richtung hat er das geschrieben. Aber ich bin halt okay. Ja doch. Ja doch. Ist es. Da
ging das ganze Video noch drum.
Okay, okay, okay. Kommt da jetzt so irgendwas? Ich meine, das ist ja nach einer Minute.
Irgendein Typ hat gesagt, er bringt eine Custom Android raus, was angeblich nicht unzensierbar
ist. Ja gut, das hat man ja schon nach 30 Sekunden erkannt, dass es Schwachsinn ist.
Der Name macht mich immer noch fertig, Alter. FreedomFoam mit FreedomOS. Das ist so hardcore
Kona. Anders kann ich das gar nicht mehr beschreiben. Eigentlich sollte das doch als Hintergrund
wenigstens eine MP5 oder sowas haben. Oder wobei MP5 ist noch zu deutsch. Eine M4 ist
doch so typisch Ami-Stels, oder? Genau, Mr. Ami. Eine M4, würde ich jetzt auch sagen.
Das wäre doch so ein typisches Ami-Ding. Überlegt euch mal, dann könnte man das auch
super customisable, customisen. Du machst dann mit einer AK bringst du das russische
OS raus, mit einer MP5 bringst du das German OS raus und mit einer M4 bringst du halt
dann das Freedom Kona OS raus. Das wäre doch was. Hilf mir 20 Monate lang, ich schnülle
jetzt ab. Da muss ich sagen, bei so Kamerabezeichnungen blicke ich eh nicht mehr durch. Ich glaube,
das heißt Front, 8MP, Rear, 13 plus 2 plus 2. Da blicke ich, ich glaube, das ist mir
zu viel. Aber trotzdem, aber trotzdem, 500 Dollar für ein Smartphone für ein Smartphone
finde ich immer noch ordentlich. Ich weiß, heute ist das Standard, aber ich finde eigentlich
500 Dollar, 500 Dollar, wir können jetzt fast in Euro umdingsen, immer noch einen ordentlichen
Preis für ein Gerät, ja. Okay, Auflösung ist nicht der Wahnsinn. Ja, was ist es für
ein CPU? Ja, okay. Okay, im Prinzip ist das relativ nichtssagend, weil die ersten 30
Sekunden ist eigentlich schon alles gesagt, es ist Schwachsinn und ja, es bleibt weiterhin
Schwachsinn. Ja, nichts. Moment, warum ist da Brave drauf? Hatten sie nicht eben noch
Dr. Go Browser gezeigt? Vor allem, vor allem. Was ist denn das? Was ist das? Was ist das
für ein Smartphone? Also wenn, wenn doch super krass Private, dann sollte es gleich
3MAR sein, oder wie spricht man das aus? 3MAR, 3MAR, 3MAR. Was ist sonst noch so drauf?
Erkennt man nicht. Oh, Umidigi, Umidigi Smartphone ist das, alles klar. Die weltbekannte, der
weltbekannte Hersteller Umidigi. Digi, Alter, Digi. Digga, Mann. Umidigi. Was zum, wie viele
Kameras haben die da dran? What the fuck? Moment, Moment, wie viele habe ich eigentlich am iPhone
dran? Zeig mal her. 2. Also ich hab hier den iPhone 11, das hat 2. Okay, okay, man könnte
sagen, es hat, es hat auch 4 so Dinger. Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt nicht, was es ist.
Ich, also ich glaube, das eine ist der Blitz, oder? Warte mal, ich kenne, ich kenne von
meinem iPhone 11, ich weiß ja nicht mal, welche Kamera was ist. Ey, so, so sieht das
aus hier, so sieht das aus. Also, das sind wahrscheinlich, warum habe ich überhaupt
zwei Kameras? Normal und Weitwinkel. Ah ja, siehst du mal. Das ist der Blitz, oder? Und
das ist irgendein Infrarotding? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Zoom? Kein Schimmer. Ich weiß, wie
sollte ich, warum ein Telefon mehr als 2 Kameras hat? Keine Ahnung. Kein Schimmer. Das ist
der Blitz, oder? Vermute ich mal. Das, das ist ein Mikrofon? Das ist doch kein Mikrofon.
Kann tatsächlich ein Mikrofon sein. Das ist ein Mikrofon, Leute. Jetzt, ich gucke da
zum ersten Mal rein. Das ist ein Mikrofon. Nice. Was, was nicht alles gibt. Teste mal,
wie gut ich über mein Smartphone Bescheid weiß. Okay, next. Aber warum hat das 6 Dinger?
Okay, Blitz. Was steht da? Megapixel AI-Kamera. Alles klar. Freedom. Naja, gut, es ist ja
auch Freedom. Freiheit, Freiheit kostet halt Geld. Ja.
Ja, im Vergleich zu iOS. Und bevor jetzt jemand kommt, ja ich weiß, man kann unter iOS auch
sideloaden, aber das ist pain in the ass zu sideloaden unter iOS, sei denn du hast gejailbraked.
iOS sideloaden ist nach 7 Tagen, glaube, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ist nach 7 Tagen,
also es geht nach einer gewissen Zeit wieder weg, das was du, was du drauf sideloadest,
sei denn du hast irgendwie ein gültiges Entwicklerzertifikaten bezahlt, so irgendwie 150 Euro im Quartal
oder so an Apple. Bin ich, weiß, ich weiß die Einzelheiten nicht genau, aber so ähnlich
ist es. Es ist eklig, das ist unter Android deutlich angenehmer. Okay, also das Video,
was? Ah. Okay, alles klar. Was auch immer, was auch immer. Also man hätte nach 30 Sekunden
eigentlich schon sagen können, ja ist halt sinnlos. Okay, der Algorithmus kriegt noch
einmal eine Chance. Nein, gibt nichts. Hier, zähl mal bitte die Kameras. Sekunde. Was ist
das denn? Was ist denn das? Was? Das ist doch ein Fake, oder? Das kannst du nicht den hier
ernst. Das, das ist doch kein, nein, das ist doch ein Fake, oder? Ist das wirklich so?
What the fuck? Was kostet das? Ah, das ist schon 2 Jahre alt. Warum? Was? Why? Das sieht
aus wie irgendein Fantasy Gegner aus dem RPG. Der kommt so auf dich zugeflogen in irgendeinem
dunklen Dungeon. Das leuchtet dann hier noch rot oder so. Okay, was war jetzt genau der
Verkaufspunkt, also warum genau sollte man sich das jetzt kaufen? Ich mein, wegen den
Kameras kaufe ich doch kein Smartphone. Ich kaufe mir ein Smartphone und natürlich, wenn
ich die Auswahl habe zwischen was mit einer guten Kamera oder einer schlechten Kamera,
nehme ich das mit einer guten Kamera. Und wenn es für mich wichtig ist, ab und zu mal
ordentliche Bilder zu machen, dann kaufe ich vielleicht auch ein teureres. Aber wenn ich
mir ein Foto kaufen will, dann ist das, also wenn ich was fotografieren will, dann ist
es doch immer besser, ich kaufe mir ein ordentliches Foto an, statt irgendwie ein Smartphone
mit 150 Kameras. Die Software dazu war super broken, hat es nicht geschafft, die Bilder
zusammensetzen. Okay, da freuen sich sicherlich alle, die das gekauft haben, wahnsinnig drüber.
Guter Reaktion Content, Zach. Vielleicht gucken wir uns das nachher noch an.
Alter, war das für ein Intro. Ja, der macht eigentlich gute Videos, der Typ. Hat der eigentlich
mal wieder ein neues Video, ähm, äh, äh, Pippewar, nee, wie hieß das? Keg W vs. Versus,
äh, wie hieß das Video? Das war ein richtig gutes Video von ihm. Keg W vs. Lul W, genau,
das Video ist einfach zu gut. Das gucken wir jetzt aber nicht, aber das ist echt nice.
Also für Leute, die viel auf Twitch sind, für Leute, die viel auf Twitch sind, jeder
andere, jeder, jeder andere wird sich wahrscheinlich denken, äh, weil guckt sich so ein Scheiß
an, aber ja, für Leute, die auf Twitch sind, ist das, ist das nice. So, also, was, was,
was können wir uns jetzt angucken? So, ja, den, den, den gucken wir uns an. Der ist,
so, vor, vor ist Biden. Jawoll. K souna ven. Sekunden' ich muss kurz Musik
ausmachen. Ich keluar villages. Na, nicht chicken concerns lock es ist. Wieviel kostet
13 Rubel.
So long.
13 Rubel Schloss. Exzellent.
Er hat doch sicherlich den special gekommenen Lockpick.
Er hat doch alles an Hardware, was man braucht, um Schleizer zu knacken.
Wenn es nicht ausreicht, dann einfach mal dreimal so lang.
Oder zehnmal so lang.
Klick Auto 4. 4 ist Binding. Die übliche Geschichte jetzt.
Pipe hat 3 angesagt.
Ach ne. Easy. Easy.
Man muss gar nichts machen außer wackeln.
Klick Auto 3. 4 ist Binding. Die übliche Geschichte jetzt.
Thanks for watching!!